So we've already factored out an x minus 2 from our original polynomial, which
leaves us with this quadratic expression, x squared minus 18 x plus 82. Now to
find the last two factors of this cubic function we started out with, we need
to find the factors of what we have left over, this new second degree
expression. Now, it doesn't look like we can just factor this. Considering I
don't know anything that multiplies to 82, but adds to negative 18. So, I think
we should use a quadratic formula. Remember that if we label the coefficients
of a quadratic expression, a, b and c, then we can find zeros of that
expression using this formula. I'll just leave it down here so you can use it
in the problem. So please do exactly what we were just discussing. Use the
quadratic formula to find the roots of x squared minus 18 x plus 82. Enter one
of them in this box and one of them in this box.